oh yes this week in absurd and appalling
point number one
yeah uh we have teen vogue
having published an article that
included an image
uh that is anatomy of a non-prostate
owner
and i don't have very much more to say
about this except no
just just
again apologies but just
[ __ ] no
no
women are being raised
this is insanity
this is that you know not again not just
the tiny tiny tiny minority of people
who are actually trans and just trying
to live their lives with some privacy
and dignity
but that
that other
somewhat but largely non-overlapping
population i would argue of trans
activists who would have us
disappear
reality in favor of
their desire to i don't even know what
in some cases i do when it's not
appropriate in some cases it's just
about power and messing with people's
heads yeah but you would say that as a
birthing and chest-feeding person
i would and as a
non-non-prostate owner i don't even know
what a non-prostate is i mean i guess i
have one
well see that's where your mathematical
literacy i think is leading you astray
well i just i actually think that i'm
also a better grammarian than would have
whoever the idiots at dean vogue are
because i i think i think what they mean
is non-owner of a prostate
not
that is evoking some song from the 80s
that i'm having
trouble placing so that's point one of
oh it's owner of a lonely heart that was
it it's not even that close owner okay
so owner of a lonely person
it's sure to be the next teen vogue
thing whatever lonely prostate how you
two can
never mind
i'm not gonna finish that sentence i
have it in my head though i'm not gonna
finish it no okay um second item from
this week and absurd nepali is
uh
oh my god
um
another thing from zero hedge this week
you may show this zachary seattle school
cancels halloween pumpkin parade says it
quotes marginalizes student of students
of color
oh my god well
it does
marginalize summer squashes
right so
i can't
do this oh my god so don't show my
screen again zach because there's all
sorts of ads that somehow my ad blocker
isn't taken care of but i'm going to
read from my screen here
this is from this article by tyler
durden in zero hedge about this
this marginalization of summer squashes
tyler durden is a is a
pseudonym yes i know yeah okay
benjamin franklin day bf day elementary
school which serves the neighborhood in
a northeastern suburb of seattle decided
to discontinue the pumpkin parade
holiday tradition this year on the
advice of the school's racial equity
team according to seattle-based
conservative radio host jason rantz in
an october 8th newsletter to parents
obtained by rants the school explained
the rationale behind the decision to
cancel the pumpkin parade which
traditionally involves a procession of
children in halloween costumes quote
halloween events create a situation
where some students must be excluded for
their beliefs financial status or life
experience end quote the letter read
quote costume parties often become an
uncomfortable event for many children
and they distract students and staff
from learning
large events create changes in schedules
with loud noise levels and crowds some
students experience overstimulation
while others must deal with complex
feelings of exclusion it's uncomfortable
and upsetting for kids
end quote instead of the halloween
festivities students at bfda elementary
may participate in fall events that are
considered more inclusive such as
you ready oh yeah quote
thematic units of study about the fall
or review autumnal artwork while quote
sharing all the cozy feelings of the
season
what
right so this this sounds like
the idea was
okay we have to make halloween
problematic let's
spitball a list of the best critiques we
can come up with and that was the damn
list
i don't personally i don't care about
halloween yep um it was never
my mother and uh
her dearest friend who was also a very
good friend of mine used to make me
these amazing costumes and they were um
they were amazing and wonderful but
halloween itself just never did it for
me it was
i i don't care about halloween this
isn't personal i'm not taking this
personally
the idea that
some
no one should be able to participate
because not everyone can participate
would be bad enough
bad enough right but this is actually
taking it one step further no one can
participate
because some people might be made
uncomfortable by it
this is again they are building they're
trying to create the illusion that a
hundred percent consensus can be created
and in less and until you have 100
consensus on any given issue
you can do nothing you are not allowed
to do a thing so what is a halloween
parade a bunch of kids dressed up and
and marching around like at one level
who cares but at another level what they
are replacing it with is thematic units
of study about the fall reviewing
autumnal artwork while sharing all the
cozy feelings of the season
this sounds like the same old same old
garbage school that we have been spoon
fed
that are much better for a particular
kind of girl style of learning than most
boy style of styles of learning sit
still be nice raise your hand when you
have to pee and have no ability to
embody anything that you're learning
ever well and we're making we're
guaranteeing that no one is going to be
able to be an adult right no we
guarantee this this is like the
last stage
uh of learned helplessness because
what the idea you know is it possible
that somebody could
put on a halloween costume that would
make you pretty [ __ ] uncomfortable
they're not even going there right but
that's not even this is just
yes obviously there are halloween
costumes that would make people
uncomfortable right
how do you draw that line not all that
freaking easy actually right um
but the point is and this was the point
for that erica you're stalking us
the best thing that ever happened to
halloween but
um yeah but
but people will say well that was for
college students and that made sense but
okay
the point is
we are teaching a lesson
right
i don't even think it's inadvertent but
if it's inadvertent that's about the
best thing you could say for it the
lesson we are teaching is that the
problem anything in which there's any
possibility of anyone stepping over any
line that might make anyone else
uncomfortable the proper thing is top
down governance upend the whole thing
and put some utopian nonsense in its
place and the point is what are the
chances i don't can't even remember what
you said about celebrating fall or
something that's not gonna be anything
there's gonna be cozy feelings of the
season autumnal artwork thematic units
of study about the fall right and the
and you know which won't include any
study of halloween or maybe that's how
we should do it you know whose rights
are being trampled here
the rights of the people who will be
disappointed because there's no
halloween thing right right and those
people do exist in large numbers as a
matter of fact i would bet they're the
majority of people you're going to
trample the rights of the majority so
that you don't hurt the feelings of some
children who probably don't even which
is exactly who may be imaginary right
right
which you know which tells us this isn't
about the children right just like about
power just like what is going on more
globally is does not appear to be about
public health this is about this it
literally somehow and i couldn't tell
you how this is true but somehow
this is about
buzzkill as an ideology
anything you like that feels familiar
you're not having fun are you right
anything that's logical right
the idea of going on a date with
somebody because you're attracted to
them and they happen to be of exactly
the sex that you would predict you'd be
most likely to be attracted to right
whatever it is is going to be made
thoroughly unfun and the whole point is
i think there are some people who aren't
having fun which you know we could feel
bad about that and we could say what can
we do about those people who aren't
having fun instead we're going to hand
them the keys to civilization and
they're going to kill everybody else's
fun in a search for equity
[Music]
you